[Music]
so we told you on Friday about the
internal documents from Twitter that
Elon Musk released gave to mattahibi who
wrote about them and then they told us
taibi and musk said that this is just
the first batch you're going to get a
lot more in days to come over the
weekend and yesterday but they never
came
that's kind of weird
the deadline came and went what happened
well we learned today what happened this
weekend Matt taibi and Barry Weiss who's
helping him do this reporting found out
that the general counsel of Twitter that
would be the former FBI general counsel
James Baker had been vetting the
documents before tahibi and Weiss could
see them in other words removing the
ones that might incriminate him or the
feds
apparently even Elon Musk who owns
Twitter didn't know this was happening
now keep in mind in case you're looking
for evidence of sinister intent this
same Jim Baker was sort of The
Architects of the Russia collusion hoax
in 2016. this is the guy who obtained
the fraudulent fighter warrants and
targeted Michael Flynn for example
so this afternoon Elon Musk fired Baker
from Twitter quote in light of concerns
about Baker's possible role in
suppression of information important to
the public dialogue he was exited from
Twitter today an amazing story that just
happened so to make sense of it we are
happy to be joined by Miranda Devine of
the New York Post who's been at the
center of the story for over two years
Brandon thank you so much for coming out
what do you make of this
hi Tucker well look as you and I
discussed on Friday night uh it was
pretty obvious that the Twitter files
that had just been released were missing
a crucial element and that was the FBI
so you know we surmised that somehow
Elon Musk had redacted it or someone had
withheld the information about the FBI's
let me ask you to pause right there
Amanda Miranda you were the only person
who said that actually it wasn't me it
was you you were the first person who
took a look at those documents and you
said someone has taken out the
incriminating stuff and I think you were
the only the only person to catch that
so I just think you deserve credit for
it yeah
thanks well so the FBI we knew had
pre-bunked uh to the social media
platforms our story before it came out
they told them to expect a pile of
Russian disinformation and Twitter was
told by the FBI we know from Joel Roth
to expect that it would be in October
and would probably refer to Hunter Biden
so we knew that there had to be
something about that at Twitter and yet
there wasn't in the Twitter files and it
was pretty obvious who was suppressing
that information who was the person with
the biggest motive it was Twitter's top
lawyer James Baker who as you just said
had been the top lawyer at the FBI the
quarterback of the FBI Russia collusion
uh Scandal and and he had had to leave
the FBI because of that and lo and
behold he shows up at Twitter five
months before the 2020 election and lo
and behold one little element did come
out in the Twitter files Friday night it
was this one email that had the date and
time removed from it very peculiarly but
it was from James Baker and it was uh
weighing in on the decision on the
morning of October 14 2020 a few hours
after our story uh came out and there
was James Baker weighing in on the side
of censorship no surprise
amazing and and as you said at the very
outset this is not just a story about
free speech on social media this is a
story about the corruption of the FBI
federal law enforcement uh and you were
absolutely right Brandon had Vindicated
once again and Tucker look
yeah Elon Musk needs to let all the
information out let us all see it no no
more of this curating and holding back
no it's ridiculous I appreciate it thank
you Miranda subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight